pop
[Musique]
on
à
mon
[Musique]
elle est à garde
furieuse elle court elle crie elle elle
pleure elle hurle le feu le feu le feu
de vente le feu elles courent cette
femme on la regarde
qui est ce elle pleure elle crie ses
cheveux flottent au vent le feu le feu
il faut que paris brûle l'espace à la
fin du mois de mai 1871 dans la commune
qui est en train de mourir
cette femme c'est louise michel 1 m 64
cheveux et sourcils bruns front aux
lieux brin negro bush moyenne menton
rond visage ovale d'un ordinaire voilà
le rapport de police tin ordinaire
peut-être mais la femme elle ne l'est
pas louise michel
c'est probablement c'est sûrement la
femme la plus extraordinaire de son
temps est ce que dit le rapport de
police n'est pas suffisant car il ne
parle pas de ce qu'il ya derrière le
regard
oui les yeux bruns mais le regard ce
qu'il ne dit pas c'est cette fois
lumineuse et ardeur cette bonté aussi
cet amour quoi elle est bonne louise
michel et elle crie qu'il faut mettre le
feu à paris et bien oui c'est le
paradoxe c'est le contraste de l'époque
le paradoxe de cette femme
et d'ailleurs elle a raison paris va
brûler alors oui on l'appelle la vierge
rouge de la commune et quand on parle
d'elle quand t'en l'imaginent c'est
toujours sur un fond de barricades
elle est à la fois un symbole et un
épouvantail
je me souviens j'étais tout enfant
c'était en 1936 pendant le front
populaire et dans ma ville natale à
lille jetés sur le trottoir
beaucoup de gens il y avait un défilé
des filets de le gréviste beaucoup de
femmes il allait vers la bourse du
travail
beaucoup de femmes qui étaient des
ouvriers revêt une nature allemand très
simplement en cheveux à l'époque c'était
une marque des tranches veux et je me
souviens qu'il y avait une dame à côté
de moi qui voyant ces femmes a dit d'un
air de mépris tout des louise michel
j'ai pas ce que c'était louise michel
j'ai demandé on m'a dit révolutionnaire
une révolutionnaire oui mais cette
révolutionnaire là est né dans un
château
oui le château devront cours et pourquoi
est elle née dans ce château bien parce
que sa mère était une fille du peuple
une orpheline qu'on avait recueilli
qu'on avait élevé avec les enfants de la
maison laurent et agathe de maïs elle
s'appelait marianne cette fille du
peuple
et puis elle était devenu grand et puis
un beau jour elle était venue en pleurs
elle avait 22 ans annoncé à madame de
maïs sa patronne qu'elle était enceinte
fallait pas chercher bien loin le fils
de la maison laurent venait justement de
s'enfuir de disparaître il ne voulait
pas de cette paternité
et alors c'est là que commence quand
même l'extraordinaire nous sommes au
xixème siècle nous sommes en 1830
nous sommes au point de vue de la morale
dans l'hypocrisie la plus absolue
d'ailleurs on parle de la bombe
vas-y absolue c'est le temps de la
bourgeoisie absolue normalement on
devrait file dehors cette domestique qui
attend un enfant
manon les deux maïs lagarde
ils savent que l'enfant qui va naître
leur petit enfant alors dans qu'ils la
gardent de maïs oui c'est une famille
noble vieille noblesse et pendant la
révolution etienne de maïs à adopter les
idées de la révolution et deux maïs il a
resserré il a enlevé sa particule et
vive la chichement d'ailleurs ils sont
pas riches les dom à izon quelques
fermes autour du château le château est
très triste
maurice barrès qui est allé visiter l'a
trouvée extrêmement mort on avec le vent
qui sifflaient d'ailleurs dans le temps
pays on l'appelle le tombeau c'est pas
très drôle il n'y a aucune fenêtre du
côté du sud cet étrange toutes les
fenêtres sont du côté du nord et voilà
qu'elle n'est cette petite fille car
c'est une petite fille on l'appelle
louise la mère s'appelle michel marian
michel naturellement on pas le nom de
son père de maïs elle pour le monde ça
mais c'est la loi et elle a entre deux
orteils une membrane or tous les deux
mais ils sont sept membres en alors on
doute plus d'ailleurs on n'a jamais
douté
voilà louise michel elle va grandir dans
ce château disons très heureux parce que
le grand père et la grand mère l'adorent
alors où elle grandit
dès qu'elle est en âge on l'envoie
l'école du village et bien dans cette
école du village et puis surtout
desquels sévir d'immenses lecture il ya
plein de livres dans le château à l'itu
sa culture viendra de là quelquefois le
soir le grand-père de maïs raconte au
coin de la cheminée des histoires de la
révolution qui l'a bien connu et il
parle de l'héroïsme de l'héroïsme des
deux côtés des blancs et des bleus il a
raison parce qu'ils adhéreront les deux
côtés et puis madame de maïs met au
piano elle apprend le piano à sa petite
fille quand elle a 15 ans louise écrit
des poèmes elle est très pieuse très
religieuse et l'écrit d'ailleurs des
poèmes religieux les bonne chrétienne
plus tard elle niera elle voudra
l'effacer de sa vie faut jamais essayé
de reconstituer son passé à l'égal de
son avenir
mal comprend pas pourquoi elle a voulu
nier cette jeunesse chrétienne parce
qu'elle était devenue anticlérical parce
qu'elle affirmait qu'elle était devenu
athée pour l'athéisme d'ailleurs je ne
suis pas très sûr l'anticléricalisme
s'explique parce que politiquement elle
était d'à côté où on affirmer que les
lits joué un rôle néfaste pour
l'émancipation du peuple alors oui elle
remet elle l'a été chrétienne
profondément saivet sont évidents à cet
égard et pense qu'il ya au contraire une
logique parce qu'elle est passée de la
foi chrétienne de la foi en dieu à la
fois dans les zones puis le grand père
meurt et la grand-mère et inquiète
qu'est ce que va devenir cette petite
quand elle disparaîtra et les généreuses
cette petite louise maurice barrès
toujours lui il était allé havre en
cours parce qu'il voulait écrire un
livre sur louise michel ne l'a pas fait
c'est regrettable
il a enquêté on lui a dit mais vous
savez l'était déjà elle avait même 12
ans 13 ans elle dérobé de l'argent ses
grands-parents pour les donner aux
pauvres
les gens venaient c'était toujours elle
qui donnait et puis un jour elle est
rentrée au château sans souliers elle
avait vu une petite pauvresse qui
avaient les pieds nus elle avait donné
ses souliers
c'était déjà ça louise michel alors la
grand mère se dit faux la mariée on
trouve un garçon un homme plutôt
beaucoup plus âgé qu'elle
il est donc ça c'est pas très grave qui
soit bonne mais il a des idées arrêtées
il veut que la femme qui les pousse soit
exactement à son image il faut qu'elle
est exactement ses propres idées qu'elle
résonne comme lui qu'elle parle comme
lui bref c'est arnold ce qu'ils
cherchaient d'agnès et louise veut pas
être agnès et la de la personnalité le
sait être l'ombre d'un homme à nant
alors adieu premier prétendant il y en a
un second celui là il est orgueilleux et
vaniteux il est gonflé de vanité et elle
trouve qu'il ressemble à une oie alors
elle veut pas être la femme dunois adieu
le deuxième prétendant et la grand-mère
mais alors laurent et agathe vendre le
château c'est fini marianne michel et sa
fille louise sont à la rue ou vente il
est bien chez un oncle et l'oncle dis à
la petite louise ya qu une solution pour
toi être institutrice
c'est vrai que pour une jeune fille qui
a reçu l'éducation une jeune fille qui a
été élevé dans un château qui ne peut
donc pas être ouvrier ou domestiques
il n'y a pas beaucoup de solutions et à
la prostitution bien sûr qui est une
solution qu'on pratique beaucoup à cet
effet et puis est institutrice alors
pourquoi pas elle sera institutrice tel
par pour chaumont pour étudier six mois
en six mois on forme une institutrice ce
qui indique assez bien ce qu'est
l'éducation à cette époque et notamment
l'éducation des filles et elle passe par
paris
et là il se produit quelque chose depuis
l'âge de 15 ans depuis qu'elle écrit des
poèmes elle les envoie à victor hugo
tous les poètes de france à cette
époque-là envoie toujours leurs poèmes à
victor hugo et comme victor hugo est un
homme bon un homme courtois il répond et
il a répondu à la petite louise michel
alors victor hugo pour lcc son dieu il
est encore loin de victor hugo c'est pas
encore le barbu et elle est à paris elle
passe par paris elle va voir victor
et qu'est ce qui se passe alors la
problème il n'y a qu'une mention de
louise-michel dans les carnets intimes
de victor hugo qui révèle tant de choses
sur sa personnalité
elle est de 1870 est il écrit dans ses
carnets intimes promenade en voiture
avec enjolras une heure de francs 50
enjolras et à des pseudonymes de louise
michel
elle a également loué comme ceux de
nîmes parce que elle prend des prénoms
masculins ça se fait enjolras vous avez
lu les misérables c'est un personnage
d'élise et alors enjolras fiacre une
heure de francs 50 francs 50 c'est le
prix du fia mais voilà ce qu'est un
petit signe à côté de la mention vous
savez que victor hugo disait tout dans
ses carnets et qu'il avait des signes
cabalistiques et la ja n qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire
n monsieur henri guillemin qui a
déchiffré avec une patience de
bénédictin ses carnets et donc j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour monsieur en
rimes monsieur henri guillemin a cru
comprendre que ce n qui retrouve qu'on
retrouve assez souvent veut dire nu a
alors si louise michel a été une heure
en fiacre
elle s'est donc déshabiller dans le
fiacre on n'a pas l'habitude de se
déshabiller dans le fiacre pour lire
spinoza donc c'est donc qu'elle s'est
donnée à victor hugo et monsieur
d'immeubles pense que si elle celle
donnée en 1870 c'est probablement qu'il
ya eu une étape antérieure qui était en
1850 raisonnement ingénieux d'autant
plus qu'on sait que quand hugo voyait
passer un jupon devant lui il n'avait
qu'une hâte c'est dans les jupons oui
mais voilà madame edith thomas a écrit
une ville louise michel c'est la
dernière en date c'est la meilleure un
livre remarquable et elle se vante si
par n il ne faut pas avoir une autre
interprétation haine ne voudrais pas
dire nulles
mais non nous avons laissé pas du tout
la même chose
alors évidemment cette dame qui est en
fiacre avec un monsieur qui lui dit non
c'est pas du tout du tout du tout la
même chose que si elle se met nue dans
le même sial moi j'aurais tendance à
penser que madame edith thomas raison et
quand les faits elle a dit non
d'ailleurs j'en parlais tout à l'heure
quand nous serons en 70 et vous verrez
que il ya une preuve de ça et moi je
crois qu'il faut le garder sa réputation
et son surnom le vierge rouge et les
sans diplôme d'institutrice
et la voilà dans un village à le long
cou où elle ouvre une école 15 enfants 1
francs par an sans un franc par mois
elle est très pauvre
elle est la plus pauvre du village mais
ce sera toute sa vie comme ça un autre
village une autre école
la pauvreté augmente encore la voilà qui
part pour paris car on lui offre une
place dessous maîtresse dans une école
de paris chez mademoiselle voliez elle
devient institutrice un peu plus tard
elle forme une école avec mademoiselle
poulenc de majel poulain rue ou d'eau
elle est institutrice et le jeune
clemenceau la verra dans cette école
jeanne clemenceau qui est médecin qui
est dans l'opposition naturellement
farouchement républicain extrême gauche
et la voix il en parle avec gentillesse
affection il dit ben oui elle était là
dans la cour de récréation
et puis quand on est en train d'envoyer
une ribambelle d'enfants accrochée
littéralement à sa vieille jupe noire et
puis alors elle est levée
une tortue des souris blanche une
couleuvre et 20 petits jardins tout ça
pour donner des leçons de sciences
naturelles et ses enfants était
passionné par cette maîtrise et et
c'était l'école du roi pétaud dit
clemenceau mais on enseigner l enseigne
et c'était original l'enseignement oui
mais elle est dévoré d'une flamme d'une
passion intérieur louise michel et ses
traits singuliers
qu'est ce que c'est que cette passion
intérieur et bien elle aime l'humanité
elle aime les hommes
elle aime tout ce qui est là autour
d'elle les humains vous allez dire que
qu'est ce que ça veut dire aimer les
hommes et mais les humains mais vous
allez voir par exemple elle voit que
gagne ici et là des petits enfants qu'on
appelle des enfants arriérés ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui des handicapés on ne
fait rien pour eux elle se dit qu'il
faut faire quelque chose
alors elles se rassemblent avec deux ou
trois institutrices comme elle et elle
prend en main l'éducation des handicapés
et puis elle regarde également autour
d'elle elle voit les aveugles et elle
fait la lecture aux ânes et puis regarde
aussi autour d'elle et elle trouve que
cette société qui l'entourent et dur à
l'homme très dur ça m'en plains en plein
essor de l'âge industriel il n'est pas
vieux l'âge industriel ils viennent m et
si en effet la france moderne se forme
ce sillonnent de chemin de fer de canaux
si on creuse des ports si partout se
construisent des fabriques des usines
c'est la fortune de la france qui se
créent à ce moment là il ya le revers de
la médaille et à tous ceux qui
travaillent et ça c'est affreux parce
que
ces ouvriers ces ouvrières viennent de
la campagne n'ont pas de formation
souvent et surtout ils n'ont aucune
protection
paradoxalement ce qui leur a supprimé
toute protection c'est la révolution
française la loi le chapelier a fait le
malheur des ouvriers et des ouvriers ils
n'ont pas le droit de s'associer donc
pas de syndicat ils n'ont pas le droit
de grève si on s'associe si on fait la
grève en prison ils sont pieds et poings
liés à la merci des patrons et ses
patrons ne sont pas tendres du tout
c'est pas la mode d'être temps et puis
autrefois il y avait des artisans avec
quelques compagnons s'était tue
maintenant c'est inhumain
le patron ne connais pas assez durs et
il faut lire dans tous ces témoignages
de l'époque ce que c'est que le sort de
l'ouvrier le voyait d'interminables
journées des salaires de famine quand le
travail diminue on met à la porte des
milliers d'ouvriers il n'y a aucune
garantie pourquoi il faut lire ces
rapports
il ya eu des rapports qu'on appelle des
rapports de philanthropes s'il n'y a pas
des gens de gauche ces gens là c'était
des bourgeois mais les bons gens qui
avaient mon coeur il y en avait pourquoi
pas il allait étudier le sort de
l'ouvrier tout ça existe noir sur blanc
villermé adobe blanqui pas
révolutionnaire son frère faut lire tout
ça des salaires on peut pas vivre avec
ces salaires et ya pire c'est le salaire
de la femme qui a la moitié de celui de
l'homme quelque fois le cas de celui de
l'homme et louise-michel regarde samedi
mais pourquoi pourquoi la femme
pourquoi la paye ton pas de la même
manière d'abord et puis les enfants ont
travaillé huit ans avant c'était cinq
ans mais depuis 1841 on s'est bagarré du
on est arrivé à 8 ans elle les voit
passer louise-michel ces petits gosses
rachitique av
on les met dans dans les filatures sous
les métiers parce qu'ils sont plus
habiles ils passent la journée 12 heures
ou 13h en dessous des métiers rampant
pour attacher les fils dit mais est ce
que l'homme est fait pour ça
est ce que la femme fait pour ça est ce
que l'enfant est fait pour ça alors il
se dit que d'abord il faudrait éduquer
ces jeunes ouvrières elles sont
illettrés et elle va donner des leçons
aux jeunes ouvriers ça c'est la grande
idée du 19e siècle s'est vidé de hugo il
faut instruire le peuple parce que quand
le peuple sera instruit il sera plus
intelligent il pourra alors se servir
faire valoir ses droits
alors elle instruit ces jeunes gens
voyaient et là elle rencontre des
républicains comme jules favre ou eugène
pelletan et elle voit qu'il ya peut-être
une solution d'abord faire du bien c'est
bravo mais sont peut-être allés ailleurs
cette société plutôt que de chercher les
palliatifs on peut essayer de la
transformer alors la république oui la
république est l'associé napoléon iii à
ses excès ses crimes aussi contre
l'humanité pourquoi n'ayons pas peur des
mots souvent ce sont des crimes il ya
beaucoup de morts
la mortalité infantile est effrayante il
ya les logis les logements de quel droit
oblige ton des familles entières dix
personnes quelquefois dans une seule
pièce
souvenez vous de ce que victor hugo à
vue quand il est allé à lille quand il a
visité les cales c'est l'enfer sur la
terre est ce que ne faut pas faire
quelque chose pour sortir des millions
d'hommes et de femmes de l'enfer alors
oui la république 1 et puis elle s'est
dit que c'est républicain c'est très
bien mais qu'est ce qu'ils valent ils
veulent la république
bravo elle veut la république mais la
république c'est le changement de
gouvernement sait rien de plus alors
elle regarde plus loin elle découvre les
blanquistes ce sont les disciples
d'auguste blanqui à socialiste un
révolutionnaire admirable d'ailleurs
pour ses idées il passera 33 ans
présents alors lé blanquistes et puis
elle voit plus loin on lui parle de
l'international qu'est ce que c'est que
l'international c'est l'association
internationale ouvrière ça vient
d'angleterre c'est marx à l'origine
alors internationale ça veut dire plus
de frontier ça veut dire plus de gays
elle ne veut plus de la guerre
elle voudrait que tous les hommes
s'aiment elle voudrait l'amour alors
elle adhère à l'internationale elle
raconte qu'elle aime monter l'escalier
ce qui s qu'allié noir obscur comme elle
montera les marches d'un temps et
maintenant ça y est elle est militante
et un jour dans un meeting comme elle
trouve que les hommes sont trop timides
et bien elle se lève elle dit si les
hommes ne font pas la révolution
ce sera nous les femmes qui la feront et
puis à la fin du second empire pierre
bonaparte le prince pierre bonaparte tu
le journaliste victor noir il ya un
immense manifestation à neuilly pour ses
obsèques
elle va elle louise-michel sur la tombe
de victor noir et elle jure que tant
qu'il y aura des iniquités comme celle
là tant que la société ne sera pas
réformé elle louise-michel samira de
noir elle portera le deuil de la justice
et c'est vrai elle sera toujours en noir
louise michel et c'est la guerre de
soixante dix et ce dans la reddition de
napoléon iii puis immédiatement la
réaction à paris le peuple qui marche
sur le palais bourbon le 4 septembre la
république proclamée bravo où il michel
est là bien sûr et puis les prussiens
qui encercle paris et puis louise michel
qui est là on l'a formé dès garde
nationale on a formé des comités de
vigilance
ce qui effraie louise-michel c'est que
les français viennent d'élire une
assemblée nationale qui siège à bordeaux
qui est royaliste majorité royalistes
poids le roi est ce que c'est ça qui
changera la société alors elle adhère au
comité de vigilance du xviiie
arrondissement aux deux comités violence
des hommes comité vigilance des femmes
et elles rencontrent là un blanc kyste
théophile ferrer un comptable 25 ans
elle a 40 ans maintenant et elle tombe
amoureuse de ferrer
pour lui c'est l'homme dont elle a
toujours rêvé sans l'avoir rencontré
elle dira qu'elle a cru voir st juste
qu'il faut dire que quand on voit la
marque de faire et on trouve pas
beaucoup qui ressemble à sa juste mais
ça ce sont les yeux de l'amour elles
l'aiment il faut pas sourire parce que
c'est probablement le cmem sûrement le
seul hameau de louise-michel sa seule
passion et le peuple ne comprend pas il
y a deux cent mille prussiens autour de
paris ils sont 400 milles parisien dans
paris sont armés pourquoi ne fait on pas
une sortie torrential pourquoi ne fait
on pas éclater les taux et on manifeste
dans paris et louise michel et dans ses
manifestations et au mois de janvier
elles manifestent sur la place de
l'hôtel de ville avec le peuple et le
gouvernement qu'on appelle le
gouvernement la défense nationale et qui
depuis le premier jour a résolu
d'impasse défendre justement fait tirer
sur le peuple elle est là louise-michel
elle entend les balles siffler c'est sa
première confrontation et elle dit dans
ses mémoires qu'elle a regardé ces
jeunes soldats de 20 ans qui tirait des
fenêtres de l'hôtel de ville c'était des
paysans
c'était des gens qui venaient des
provinces c'était des gens aussi pauvres
que ceux sur qui ils tiraient elle était
fascinée la regardent et disent alors on
peut tout fait avec des sommes qu'ils
savent pas et puis les prussiens ventre
dans paris une journée seulement les
parisiens transportent les canons qui
l'ont payé pendant le siège qu'ils ont
fait fondre de leur donner les
transporte sur les hauteurs de
montmartre pour que les prussiens n'en
parle pas et maintenant il y a le
gouvernement provisoire de monsieur
thiers et ça gêne ce gouvernement
provisoire que les parisiens dont on
n'est pas sûr possède des canons et le
18 mars 1871 le gouvernement de monsieur
thiers prend la décision de sans
paraître c'est cannes qui sont gardés
par le peuple par les gardes nationales
et à l'aube les soldats investissent la
butte montmartre
on chasse les gardes nationaux on sent
par les canons normalement les chevaux
doivent arriver les à plage
avec des prolongements artillerie parce
qu'il faut bien tiré avec quelque chose
c'est canon il n'arrive pas ça s'éteint
un de ses ordres mal le nez qui cause
quelques fois la révolution elle est là
louise michel à la permanence du 61ème
bataillon de montmartre et elle apprend
justement convient de se saisir de ces
canons elle crie au secours
alarme on se mobilise théophile ferrer
et là ils ont chacun fusil ils montent à
l'assaut de la bvk mans la butte
montmartre ils pensent qu'ils vont
mourir parce qu'ils pensent trouver
l'armé hostile et quand il n'arrive pas
du tout c'est fini qu'est ce qui s'est
passé bien c'est que peu à peu à mesure
que la matinée s'avancer on attendait
toujours les chevaux et les gens le
montmarte sont venus voir ses soldats
les femmes notamment leur a parlé on
leur refaire du café c'est pas une très
bonne atmosphère
el général le conte tout à coup elle a
crié à la foule de se disperser allez
vous non
et comme cette foule ne voulait pas
enlever le sang allait le général le
compte à trier tirer dans le tas feu pas
un soldat l'attirait et un sous-officier
a crié crosse en l'air s'était fait la
troupe avaient fraternisé avec le peuple
et le pauvre le contrat d'ailleurs
fusiller un peu plus d'un et c'est la
situation que trouve louise-michel quand
elle arrive elle est heureuse
ainsi donc ces soldats n'oublie pas d'où
ils viennent
et comme ce tir apprendre à sly bien
terrorise il quittera paris avec le
gouvernement pour versailles ses filets
la commune va se créer dans paris
monsieur pierre a créé délibérément les
conditions de la commune
il aa plan il reviendra un jour pour
chasser les communards et pour anéantir
les ferment révolutionnaire de paris la
commune
pour louise michel c'est d'abord
l'ascension théophile ferrer qui devient
l'un des personnages les plus importants
de la commune elle est heureuse ravis
que ferrer soir lahoud
et puis aussi ce sont ces réformes que
votre la commune qui lui plaît sur
l'enseignement sur l'assistance sur le
droit au travail est là à rêver à ce
large jusque là et ça se fait ça se fait
évidemment dans des conditions qui sont
presque insolite
cette ville est encerclée cette ville
tout esprit lucide doit sentir qu'elle
n'a pas d'avenir et pourtant il est en
train de recréer une société dans des
conditions qui font que très
probablement toutes ces réformes qu'elle
fait ne pourront jamais être appliquée
mêle les faits c'est un rêve éveillé qui
se créent dans l'instant et c'est pour
ça que quand nous pensons à ces gens de
la commune où nous pouvons y penser qu
avec tendresse elle elle est furieuse
contre monsieur thiers et elle annonce à
la commune qu'elle vais aller me tuer
comment tuer oui je vais aller vers
sages veulent tuer alors ont ils dit non
on n'y va pas d'ailleurs tu ne pourras
jamais aller à versailles qu'il faut pas
le tuer parce que la province entière
fera bloc après autour de monsieur
pierre alors elle renonce à tuer tir
mais elle va quand même à versailles
traversant les lignes rapportent des
journaux de versailles pour montrer
qu'elle a été à versailles
et puis quand on se bat au mois d'avril
elle est là elle a sans cesse elle s'est
occupée des enfants depuis le siège
d'ailleurs car on avait faim en manger
les rats des chiens des chats et avec
les manceaux à laver assurer la
subsistance des enfants elle même elle
n'avait rien elle même elle ne mange
rien elle mourrait de froid sur son lit
avec une vieille couverture de choix les
hugo lui avait donné de l'argent pour
s'acheter une vraie couverture elle
avait distribué l'argent pauvres alors
gaulle y avait dix jours donne de
l'argent mais vous me jurez que c'est
vraiment pour acheter une couverture la
vie dit non alors ne me donnez pas
d'argent parce que je sais bien que je
le distribue ray on se bat mois d'avril
elle est ambulancière elle soit il est
blessé puis
elle trouve ça trop passif elle veut
participer elle veut défendre cette
commune qui illustrent ces idées
profondes
alors elle s'engage on lui donne une
très belle carabine remington et elle se
bat on la voit ici on la voit moulineaux
on la voit à clamart à clamart
d'ailleurs au milieu de la bataille on
se bat autour d'une église abandonnée
elle lâche le combat à l'instant pour
entrer dans l'église et jouer de l'orgue
bah oui elle est musicienne dans ça lui
fait plaisir
aissi clemenceau la voix mais à le voir
qui c'est extraordinaire ce que j'avais
vu du clemenceau
elle est là elle fait le trou dessus
elle a horreur de tuer mais les objets
tuer pour que les autres soient pas tués
et elle est désespérée de ça mais elle
se bat elle s'expose à chaque instant
comment n'at-elle pas été tués sans foi
incroyable
elle est sur la barricade de neuilly
elle aperçoit un chat entre les lignes
alors il quitte la barricade pour aller
chercher le chat elle adore les animaux
pas seulement les hommes les animaux
et puis elle est dans paris quand les
versaillais le 21 mai 1871 entre par
surprise
ils sont vingt-cinq mille on leur a fait
la leçon leur a dit à ces jeunes gens de
20 ans on leur a dit n'y a que des
assassins dans paris tous les hommes
tous les communards sortent de prison
toutes les femmes sont des prostituées
quant aux enfants ils sortent des
maisons de correction alors pas de pitié
et le journal de versailles imprimer la
veille pas de prisonniers il faut que
les soldats fassent dans l'instant et
dans la rage ce qu'il n'oserait plus
faire le lendemain et ils le font croyez
le elle avance de rue en rue de quartier
en quartier de blocs de maisons en blocs
de maisons tout les communards comprend
contre un mur fusil et pas de pitié les
femmes les hommes les vieillards tout le
monde c'est une tueriie effrayante on
n'en a pas vu à paris comme celle là
depuis des siècles alors elle est au
début dans le cimetière montmartre
qu'elle défend avec les fédérer les obus
frappent régulièrement le cimetière
montmartre à nos bus écrase un arbre en
fleurs de ce moment à l'ue mais les
fleurs tombe sur elle elle ramasse ses
fleurs va les porter sur la tempe de mur
j'ai l'auteur de la vie de bohème et
puis sur la tempe de mademoiselle
poulain son ancien associé à l'école et
puis les versailles arrive il faut
courir il faut quitter ce cimetière il
faut aller vers une barricade puis une
autre barricade
ce qui est effrayant c'est que cette
semaine cette semaine qu'on appelle la
semaine sans gras et bien la résistance
et une peau de chagrin
les versaillais arrivent de partout se
resserre alors les hommes les femmes
sont la place blanche il ya 100 femmes
qui défendent une barricade
et puis elle est là elle au château
d'eau marie kaddes du delta ils sont
sept pour la défense et puis bientôt ils
sont trois et elle voit arriver des
gares nationaux des renforts elle crie
veulent et venez nous ne sommes que
trois et puis ce ne sont pas des gardes
nationaux ce sont les versaillais
déguisés en gardes nationaux alors les
deux sont immédiatement fusillé l on l'a
bousculons la frappe
elle est évaluée on la croit morte on la
jette dans un fossé elle n'est pas morte
elle se réveille un peu plus tard elle
s'enfuit et c'est alors qu'elle pousse
ce cri le feu le feu le vent thomas
barrage de flamel pense que c'est la
seule solution pour les arrêter at elle
mis le feu menon les incendies qui
commence à ce moment là sont dans un
autre quartier de paris sont les
tuileries c'est la cour des comptes
c'est la légion d'honneur
l'hôtel de ville elle n'est pas du tout
par là
ce cri qu'elle a poussé bien ses
réflexes profond personne n'a
délibérément mis le feu il ya des hommes
des femmes qui ont mis lé feu médias
jamais eu par exemple de pétroleuses on
l'a démontré
les études récentes le démontrent et
pourtant toutes les femmes que les
versailles ont pris portant un bide
ont raconté au versailles et vous savez
on a distribué du pétrole à des femmes
et elles vont verser ce pétrole sur les
monuments ce sont les pétroleuses alors
une femme qui va faire le marché il faut
bien sortir aller chercher le lait des
enfants alors malheur à la femme qu'on
rencontre avec un bidon avec du lait on
l'a fusil c'est du pétrole et celle qui
a une bouteille pour aller chercher de
l'eau à la fontaine fusillés des
centaines de femmes sont fusillés comme
pétroleuses or il n'y a pas eu de
pétrole
les comédiens ont fusillé les otages ils
ont eu tort le système des acteurs est
affreux 85 m'en mêler versailles et
fusils trente mille personnes
trente mille les derniers combats les
dernières barricades qui tombe
la dernière bataille dans le cimetière
du père lachaise de tombes entendent
toute la nuit horrible c'est fini le sol
de paris dira monsieur thiers est
jonchée de leurs cadavres ce spectacle
affreux servira de leçon c'est la
dépêche qui est envoyé au préfet alors
depuis toujours elle n'est pas rentrée
chez elle louise elle rentre chez les
voisins me dit ah on est venus en bus
venu pour te prendre bon j'étais pas là
tant mieux mais on a pris ta mère et oui
marianne la vieille marjah où sont les
prisonniers aux bastions électoraux
mastien et elle trouve sa mère avec les
autres prisonniers
elle se présente aux autorités
versaillais je suis louise michel à ses
toiles au rize michel oui c'est moi
laisser partir ma mère puisque je suis
là on laisse partir la mer et les
prisonniers avec les autres le troupeau
qui s'en va à pied à versailles ce
troupeau d'hommes
de tous les âges de femmes de vieillards
de tout ce qu'on peut imaginer une
marque qui sont des milliers et des
milliers des milliers qui marche à pied
vers le bois de boulogne et à la muette
qui a le général gadi fait et de loin
louise le voile général de gas lift et
les sur son cheval et le malaise érable
troupeau s'avance se scinde en deux pour
passer de part et d'autre du cheval il a
une cravache le général galy fait ils
montrent certains de ceux qui passent
près de lui lui celui là celui ci alors
on l'est on les emmène un peu plus loin
derrière un bosquet une salle fusillé il
dit la journaliste anglais correspondant
du times ont beau paul suspects et
qu'ils aient pu me demander mais qu'est
ce qui motivait son choix il s'est rendu
compte que il ne faisait pas bon être
trop grand ou trop petits ou est trop
rouge ou trop pâle ou avoir un nez trop
long tout ce qui diffère pensiez
légèrement de la normale fusion et
louise le dit dans ses mémoires jeudi je
vais être fusillé n'en elle passe et
quand on arrive à faire ça et bien là il
ya autre chose y aller vers ça y est les
femmes les hommes les gants d'un an
toilettes printanière les femmes ont des
ombrelles
elle essaie de crever les yeux des
prisonniers qui sont là ce charmant faut
que la police la troupe les protège la
prison
satori des milliers de prisonniers elle
est là au milieu des autres et elle
comparaît devant le magistrat militaire
instructeur et alors que certains oui
tout le monde n'est pas un héros
certains essayent de minimiser leur rôle
parmi les survivants elle elle avoue
tout elle reconnaît tout elle dit plus
qu'elle et elle pense à ferrer théophile
ferrer qui n'a pas été fusillé qui a été
pris et il est dans sa prison il ya des
lettres d'une prison à l'autre de belles
lettres lettres d'amour de sa part est
louise lettres d'amitié de la part de
théophile ferrer
et on le juge condamné à mort
alors elle écrit à tout le monde il faut
sauver ferrer impossible on ne sauve pas
à ferrer il est fusillé etc pour l
écroulement le désespoir et elle paraît
à son tour devant le tribunal elle ne
veut pas d'avocat elle se défendre à
elle même et on l'a dépeint comme la lie
sorti de la ligue la société comme les
mieux public numéro un
le commissaire de la république dit il
faut l'araignée de la société c'est un
danger
louise michel elle a la parole se défend
il dit c'est vrai messieurs je suis un
danger pour la société
parce que moi je refuse la société telle
qu'elle est je ne veux pas que l'on
exploite des millions d'hommes je ne
veux pas que on le condamne à la misère
à la famine et la maladie que c'est leur
enfant meurt tu ne veux pas que leurs
femmes soient contraintes à la
prostitution
je ne veux pas je ne me résigne pas je
me battrai toute ma vie pour que cela ne
soit plus alors messieurs
oui je suis dangereuse alors messieurs
monsieur le commissaire de la république
a eu bien raison il faut me rayer de la
société je ne vous demande qu'une chose
c'est d'être fusillé tous mes amis sont
morts les derniers ont été conduits au
peloton d'exécution à satory conduisait
moi je vous le demande
vous auriez tort de ne pas me faire
fusiller parce qu'attention si j'ai la
vie sauve je vous déclare la guerre
éternellement je serai votre ennemi
jusqu'au bout messieurs si vous n'êtes
pas la codah mémoire
jamais on n'a entendu un tel discours
c'est une femme qui parle
il y un silence dans la salle inwi il y
à des journalistes de toutes les
tendances
il faut lire la presse deux ans ma si
certaines feuilles
bon évidemment la traîne dans la boue et
d'autres qui ne sont pas des feuilles de
gauche qui sont une feuille
conservatrice dans ses articles y ait du
respect parce que quelqu'un qui va ce
point jusqu'au bout de ses idées et
respectable elle est profondément
respectable louise michel
et voyez-vous ces magistrats militaires
noces balle
peut-être alors est-il condamné à mort
si justement elle avait été elle avait
essayé de noyer le poisson mais comme
elle a parlé de façon justement on la
condamne pas m'at elle est condamné à la
déportation dans une enceinte fortifiée
elle sera embarqué en ou 73 à rochefort
sur une frégate dieye frégates à voile
la virginie elle part elle est condamné
à la déportation à la nouvelle calédonie
c'est là qu'on envoie les condamnés de
la commune et sur cette vieille frégates
et bien on a construit deux cages une
cage pour les armes une cage pour les
femmes alors au départ et bien on a
compté l'argent des femmes qui
s'embarque l on a les documents une
femme sans douce france
d'une feinte 91 prend une femme 77
francs louise michel de francs 50
elle n'a absolument rien lors lui remet
un baluchon ce sont ces vêtements pour
la déportation toutes les femmes
reçoivent ces vêtements et le bateau
glisse vers le sud les canaris elle se
lie mais ce que c'est pas les restes de
l'atlantide
elle écrit des poèmes parce qu'elle
écrit toujours des poèmes et il y a dans
ses poèmes des éclats des éclairs et
puis on glisse vers le pôle sud on va
tourner le sud de l'amérique du sud il
fait très froid c'est le cap des
tempêtes la glace sur le bateau et elle
elle tremble dans ces petits vêtements
parce que comme il y avait des femmes
qui avaient foi leur a donné ses
vêtements lorraine le plus petite jupe
de mérinos et rochefort henri rochefort
l'homme de la lanterne qui lui aussi a
été condamné était dans la cage des
hommes qui la voit de loin voix avec
terreur qu alors que la glace partout
elle est à pieds nus elle a donné ses
chaussettes elle a donné ses chaussures
à une fille plus jeune qui avait froid
et le commandant du bateau sédiments
fins peux pas la laisser comme ça et le
commandant vient voir au choix d'écouter
ce qui lui donne des chaussons elle
refusera parce que le dira le commandant
sais quel représentant de la société
alors vous voilà des choses sont faites
plus passer les chaussons comme venant
d' et c'est ce que ces roches peu ont
fait passer le chausson rosport cris
prenez ces choses sont elles les prendre
et roches mardi dans ses mémoires je lui
ai vu ses shows sont là
dans deux jours au pied le troisième
jour les chaussons et au pied d'une
autre pas quatre mois la nouvelle
calédonie là c'est le choc
elle est émerveillée par les paysages
qui tout à coup se dessine devant tel
qu'une nature qu'elle n'aurait pas
imaginé c'est une sorte d'autres rêves
éveillés
elle est moins émerveillé quand on la
cantonne avec les autres condamnés dans
la presqu'île du co où ils sont obligés
de construire eux mêmes leur demeure
j'ai vu cette presqu'île du corps où il
n'y a plus rien au monde quand même
encore de de vieille maison où habitait
des déportés de la commune et là elle
sera ce qu'elle a toujours été cela sera
toujours elle ne pensera causant elle
soigne les malades clemenceau lui envoie
de l'argent elle le donne aux plus
pauvres
on lui envoie des vêtements elle les
donne les incultes et les ce qu'ils sont
ils étrennent leur apprends ali elle
s'est fait donner une mission par la
société de géographie étudier les
peuplades kanak elle les étudie une
mission par le société d'acclimatation
elle plantes des graines pour qu'il y
ait à la nouvelle calédonie de nouvelles
essences je ne pense pas qu'il y ait
beaucoup de banias qu'ils se soient fait
donner en même temps deux missions
scientifiques et puis surtout elle
découvre les kanaks les habitants l'île
elle les aime
anna elle les trouve vrai authentique
elle les aime d'autant plus que les
autres ne les aime pas parce que c'est
communards ces gens c'est
révolutionnaire ea dont les réflexes de
leur temps alors c'est le temps de la
colonisation ils sont sûrs qu'on apporte
le bonheur à ces gens là elle en est pas
si sûr
elle essaie de le démontrer aux
communards leur disant vous avez tort
elle aime le kanak et eux comme ils se
sentaient mail m
elle fait ce qu'elle peut pour eux en
1878 il ya une grande révolte kanak la
chose curieuse les gens de la commune
font bloc avec l'armée parce que ce sont
des blancs y commander sauvage qui se
révèle elle louise-michel épouser la
cause des kanaks
elle apprend même au kanak a coupé les
fils télégraphie elle est dans le droit
fil de ce qu'elle a toujours pensé
en 1979 elle a le droit d'aller à nouméa
comme des portes est libre si on peut
dire et elle forme une école pour les
enfants des déportés et une école pour
les kanaks et les kanaks aime entendre
louise-michel leur parler parce que
quand ils apprennent à lire à écrire et
ils ont l'impression d'être un peu plus
libre on parle d'elle en france elle est
devenue très connue depuis son procès et
puis il ya les déportés qui rentre et
qui disent 'vous savez voilà ce que
louise michel
il ya dans les archives de la police un
rapport unique je crois dans ce genre
darchy un rapport qui dit vis-à-vis des
employés de l'administration
pénitentiaire louise michel est
considérée comme une sainte cherché
cherché longtemps vous trouverez pas
beaucoup de rapport de police donnant un
tel jugement de l'administration
pénitentiaire alors on demande sa grâce
il ya des journaux qui ouvre des
pétitions il faut gracié louise-michel
elle refuse l écrit au président de la
république je ne veux pas de grâce je
partirai la dernière quand vous aurez
amnistié tous les condamnés et on
amnistie en 1880 tous les condamnés
c'est peut-être à cause d elle prend le
bateau les kanak sont sur le quai il
pleure il ya des centaines de canards
with louise ne t'en va pas elle crie
qu'elle reviendra alors viendra pas mais
elle le pense quand elle le dit londres
le havre le train la gare saint lazare
elle est là dans son wagon avec deux
amis descendent elle croître seul dans
la gare quelle surprise
la gare est plein de gens la cour toutes
les rues
il y a vingt mille personnes qui sont
venues accueillir louise michel
elle est là et elle pleure comment moi
qu'est-ce que je suis qu'est-ce que je
ne compte pas et on embrasse il ya là
clemenceau il ya la rochefort qui s'est
évadé lui avant elle et elle reste un
instant elle ne veut pas de gloire elle
s'en va voir sa mère raconte la vieille
marianne et elle reprend le combat oui
le combat parce que ce qu'elle ne tolère
pas existe toujours
l'exploitation des ouvriers des
ouvrières l'inégalité entre les hommes
et les femmes le travail des enfants pas
de garanties pas d'assistance pas de
droit au travail
il faut changer ça et elle lutte et
comment peut-elle lutte est elle qui est
toute seule elle ne fait pas vraiment
partie d'un parquet at elle une
appartenance politique ce dont on peut
être sûr c'est que quand un parti de
gauche et plus persécutée qu'un autre
alors elle s'y jette au fond elle est
anarchiste
c'est ça louise michel le supporte pas
de joux et surtout elle est tenue par un
mot un seul l'amour est laid mais elle
pense que tant les hommes sèmeront tout
sera résolu alors seul qu'est ce qu'elle
peut faire bien elle parle bien sûr et
les cris est là et beaucoup écrit elle a
écrit des vers je vous ai parlé de
sévères y en a de très beaux elle a
écrit des romans ils ne sont pas très
bons dix ans le des pièces de théâtre
sans nom
parlons pas des pièces de théâtre l
écrire un livre sur la commune s'est
désolée la un livre qui lui est très
beau si vous le trouvez lisez le
mais ce n'est pas par les cris qu'elle
fait connaître ce qu'elle sent en elle
c'est par la parole et la dont elle
s'étale et ça dure 25 ans imaginez
pendant 25 ans cette femme qui n'arrête
jamais qui va de ville en ville on la
lance quelques lignes dans un journal
louise-michel parlera au théâtre
municipal teller lda et la salle est
pleine
les gens viennent l'entente elle est là
toute frêle dans sa robe noire sur la
scène et elle parle et les souffrances
du peuple qu'elle dépeint tous ces gens
qui sont assis dans la salle les ressent
avec elle et ces gens sont atterrés par
ce qu'on leur raconte et les condamnés
de la commune qu'elle vénère quand elle
parle d'eux de leur sacrifice de leur
mort est bien tous ces gens qui sont
assis là ces gens pleurent et quand elle
parle de l'avenir radieux de la société
change et d'un monde meilleur
heureux plus juste les gens le voient et
on l'acclament et on l'aiment et elle
s'en va et elle va de ville en ville
elle va ailleurs elle reparle parle
d'autre chose
dès qu'il y a une cause injuste elle la
dénonce
dès qu'il ya quelqu'un à se courir elle
y va elle est sans cesse mobilisés elle
se mobilise elle même chômage à paris
très forte époque de chômage vous savez
il ya toujours eu enfin souvent du
chemin et là ils veulent pas de
garanties pas d'indemnités de chômage
imaginer le chômage un ouvrier en
showman qui a des enfants
qu'est ce qui se passe on meurt de faim
et on meurt de faim alors elle fait un
appel chômeurs place de lave des
invalides avec moi quel jour quinze
mille chômeurs sur la place de la mairie
des lilas toute seule petite femme frêle
masse elle dit il faut que nous
manifestions
nous avons la force et nous ne nous ont
pas mais nous nous devons montrer cette
force alors suivez-moi nous allons
montrer à ces gens que nous sommes
l'armée les travailleurs et il traverse
paris derrière elle elle brandit le
drapeau noir
et puis alors comme ils ont faim ils
sont devant une boulangerie il s'arrête
ils prennent le pain est alors elle crie
surtout ne faites pas de mal aux
boulangers parce que oui la révolution
mais sans qu'on fasse de mal à personne
et elle continue avec quelquefois des
incidents qui sont des accidents ou
havre elle parle un forcené pénètre sur
la scène par derrière et à bout portant
lui tire une balle dans la tête alors on
essaiera l'opérer trois fois pour tirer
la balle on ne pourra pas elle aura
toujours cette balle dans la tête et
c'est vous ce qu'elle fait la première
chose qu'elle demande surtout qu'on ne
lui fait pas de mal
et puis après quand on l'arrête le
forcené qu'on juge elle remue la france
entière
pourquoi surtout on ne lui fasse pas de
mal elle écrit au président de la
république elle écrit aux journaux elle
est là pour témoigner pour lui et lui
dit me voyons vous voyez bien c'est un
moment d'hallucinations qui a écouté il
ya une femme il a des enfants
vous ne pouvez pas le mettre en prison
qu'est ce que deviendrait sa femme et
ses enfants et on la quitte parce
qu'elle l'a demandé puis alors épisode
un peu comique
un jour un bourgeois un commerçant riche
commerçant vient la voir lui il faut
briller un journal à un journal oui vous
pourrez dire ce que vous pensiez dans le
journal mais vous savez c'est pas dans
votre sens que jefferson sait rien dire
aux gens vous avez j'ai gagné beaucoup
d'argent dans le commerce et maintenant
j'ai des remords je me demande si cet
argent je ne vais pas gagner aux dépens
du peuple alors je vous donne tout
l'argent vous voulez pour ela ce journal
qui paraît et le bourgeois et toujours
avec elle désormais elle introduit dans
les milieux révolutionnaire on lui fait
fait dès qu'il ya un comité il est là
dès qu'on fait des préparatifs dès qu'on
fait des plans d'action il est toujours
là ce bon bourgeois
jusqu'au jour où on s'aperçoit que ces
bourgeois n'est pas du tout la bourgeois
mais un agent de police qui a été
envoyée là par le préfet de police
andrieu qui s'est dit grâce à la bonne
louise-michel je vais introduire un
mouchoir au sein de
tous les comités révolutionnaires
comment voulez vous que les pu déceler
une telle manoeuvre
et puis à la duchesse d'uzès aussi elle
a fait la connaissance de la duchesse
d'uzès comme elle est toujours très
féministe louise michel n'oublions pas
jamais son combat féministe qui est très
important l'égalité des droits pour la
femme pour l'homme l'égalité des
salaires surtout la duchesse d'uzès et
féministe alors cette grande dame qui
est une des plus riches de france
mais louise michel sont devenus amis ce
qui fait que quand un compagnon
révolutionnaire et jeté en prison qu'on
a besoin un peu d'un peu d'argent pour
un avocat elle écrit tout de suite à la
duchesse vite un peu d'argent et c'est
la duchesse qui paye
amusant elle vieillit mais elle continue
parce qu'elle croit toujours
elle est sûre elle est sûre que ce monde
meilleur est pour bientôt
elle est sûre que la société changera
elle vieille elle est fatiguée elle va
toujours de ville en ville
elle parle 1905
elle est épuisée marseille l'appel il
faut qu'elles viennent on a besoin
d'elle et quand on l'appelle elle va
toujours kalivas elle arrive et quand
elle arrive le 5 janvier 1905 elle sa
lite la fièvre à l'hôtel de l'oasis
boulevard dugommier un médecin double
congestion pulmonaire
elle meurt le 9 janvier à 10 heures elle
a 75 ans on ramènera son corps à paris
et on la conduira au cimetière de
levallois perret où l'attend déjà depuis
longtemps ça mais la pauvre marianne
alors pour cet enterrement le pouvoir a
peur on a mobilisé la troupe les
fantassins les gendarmes à cheval tout
la police des centaines et des centaines
d'hommes
jusque là on avait peur d'une petite
femme en noir maintenant on a peur d'un
cadavre de femme en noir
et savez vous combien de parisiens vont
suivre le cortège cent mille 100 1000
parisien qui suivent et qui pleure
louise michel
parce que louise michel et mais les
hommes et demandé qu'on aime les a je
pense à louise michel
je pense à ce petit lit de l'hôtel de
l'oasis à marseille où elle a rendu
l'âme
je pense à ce qu'elle a dû penser avant
de fermer les yeux pour jamais elle a
pensé qu'il fallait être un peu patient
mais que bientôt on toucherait au but
elle était sûre qu on toucherait au but
elle était sûr que le jour viendrait où
il n'y aurait plus d'injustice dans le
monde où il n'y aurait plus de
frontières où il n'y aurait plus de
guerre
elle en était sûr et je suis sur moi que
louise michel est morte heureuse à ce
qu'elle en était si comme on l'était sur
victor hugo lisez ce qu'écrit hugo sur
le xxème siècle tous les problèmes
devraient être résolus au xxème siècle
il fallait attendre avec impatience le
20e siècle et je pense à louise michel
morin je pense aussi à hugo je suis
épouvanté comme voulait parce que qu'est
ce que nous avons fait nous de leurs
espérances plus gai de guerre mondiale
la science qui devait tout résoudre
effacer la sueur des hommes
la science a servi à faire ce que vous
savez un un déchaînement le mort et le
socialisme le socialisme qui transfigure
est littéralement louise michel
au nom du socialisme le boulade
l'extermination la torture est
maintenant au nom du socialisme le
génocide
mais si elle était là louise michel cody
ray tél nous l'avons trail nous
cher l'humanité a trahi les espoirs de
l'humanité du 19e siècle et nous n'avons
pas être très fiers de nous croyez le
holocauste extermination univers
concentrationnaire
qu'avons nous fait alors elle a rêvé
louise michel
alors louise michel était inutile alors
ce combat était inutile
faut pas croire ça non et je le crois
pas je crois qu'il faut qu'il y ait à
toutes les époques de l'humanité des
gens qui se lèvent qui dénonce qui crie
qui appelle
il faut un las casas qui dénonce le
massacre des indiens
il faut un volt et qui crient pour la
tolérance et pour qu'on réhabilite
gallas il faut un zola qui crient pour
qu'on rende justice à dreyfus il faut il
faut une louise michel
[Musique]